there's some interesting things to like
I've kind of noticed that a lot
especially in a lot of megachurches in
LA cuz I you know I shopped around four
different churches to see which one I
liked yeah and I I found something very
fascinating dude Church is too
depending on which one you go to some of
it's just a [ __ ] businessman it's
it's a big business [ __ ] huge
multi-million dollar business give me
money and I'll make you feel better
that's all it is yeah it's it's it was
so different from the churches that I
grew up in you know and that's the
reason why I'll be it they probably
struggled financially because they were
they were focused more on the teachings
of the religion than they were about
grabbing people and for their money and
which is what I grew up with so when I
came to LA that was another big test
that I had I was like damn [ __ ] these
churches man but money grubbing says the
[ __ ] yeah why are these [ __ ]
pastors talking about like I'm trying to
help people out but you got a
multi-million dollar mansion dude well
it makes because they they basically
enable and make a lot of the greedy
people feel good about themselves yeah
cuz they're like they're like yeah you
know you deserve that expensive car you
deserve this and that oh yeah yeah and
then they feel good so they give more
offering because they feel like they're
giving to God too because deep down
inside they do feel to read or whatever
it is I'm used to like the pastor's that
I grew was like even my dad right so
might where my dad started started up a
church in Sacramento because we had our
own business he was wanted like the
Deacons there and he started up that
church with one of his close friends he
didn't take a paycheck from the church
dad at all ever and that's how it should
be yeah cuz he had his own source of
income yeah and we weren't even rich
either it's not like our family couldn't
have used it yeah you know but my dad
did it and he worked at that church
tirelessly and I really respect that
about him and a lot of the other
people's of the church all those deacons
like I really respected that out of them
you know and so when I saw the opposite
that happened in some of this you know
I'm not saying they don't work hard but
I it always made me feel weird when I
saw yo be making seven figures is
definitely living beyond your regular
means well I don't think a pastor should
ever make seven figures yeah I believe
that they could they should make a good
living because they are doing all [ __ ]
ton of work but seven figures I mean
when it comes to religion I personally
just have
makes me feel weird about Rockstar
religious people yet they're rock stars
that's what they are they start to
become these rock stars because they're
too powerful yeah they're not to me I
feel like they're not servicing the the
higher peoples I mean the hot the Spears
he's like they're servicing themselves
exactly mmm they're basically sucking
their own [ __ ] dick they're taking
the attention away from the spirits I I
saw this too and it was so I went to
this church and I was so curious because
so there was a person that in the crowd
that asked so it within the Protestant
religion homosexuality is a sin right so
stealing and all that other stuff right
and this person asked the pastor this is
what he says he goes so what what is the
Christian belief on homosexuality and
what is your opinion on it right and he
goes is is it a sin or is it not and
he's in the Bible it says it's a sin he
didn't say that though oh this is what
he said he goes there are people who
were gay that come to this church and I
love them too and you know I have I grew
up with a you know some people who were
gay and he was like why can't he just
admit that it's a sin he wouldn't do it
because I would have just been like yes
it's a sin just like lying is a sin
which we all do so we all live with sin
so he was I I was like what is he wait
hold on a second what is he doing and
then he and they asked again and this
person said to this pastor he goes
that's not what I asked
they go what is what I'm asking is what
what is your opinion and what does the
church say about it he goes goes back to
it again beats around the bush well you
know I've had homosexual people come up
to me and say that they love this church
and the person was like yo basically
he's making a big thing I don't want to
lose my customers that's what he was
saying I want to lose my customer I lost
so much respect for him dude because no
matter whether I agree or disagree with
what he was gonna say as a religion you
should have a stance yeah
or as anybody with a serve have a
[ __ ] stance dude and be able to
defend it or or not even defend it just
you or you weren't worried about you
what your beliefs were you were worried
about losing your customers right and I
was like holy [ __ ] this is a business
boom boom moment for me dude and I
looked at this pastor saying like you
could've just
said yes it's a sin in the religion but
we're also a faith about love and
everybody's welcome here man mm-hmm
everybody's welcome here like you're
welcome here you know let's list all
love you Jane who hasn't like everyone
broke something in the Bible yo man I'm
breaking [ __ ] all day yeah and haven't
even even thoughts about sinning is
actually a sin itself yeah Ennis it's
like so I mean who is without sin like I
mean and why can't you just admit that
it is yeah why can't you sex before
marriage is this lying is a sin like
everything that we do is already a sin
within the religion yeah and I I gotta
say too like I can't even in that I
can't judge every church for for that
what that guy did I can't say every
Church is like that even though this is
not this is not a nebulous statement or
a comment I'm just saying what I saw
made me feel of a certain way about this
church and which is why I left it yeah
because I felt like people and also at
this church they talked about tithing
way too much so you knew it was the
business when they passed the offering
table more than one time during a sermon
I'm just like this is not that dude the
dude talked about tithing I think like
nine out of ten times I was there God
like bro we get it you want 10% of the
[ __ ] paycheck I [ __ ] get it can
you get to the [ __ ] sermon dude like
that's what it was constantly about you
know what I do like about mega churches
though they are entertaining as oh they
got murdered
yeah they got like angels flying from
the sky and [ __ ] they got full-on bands
like video of that dude [ __ ] cable
coming down floating yeah and then had
to be spun back around and [ __ ] dude
I've been to one where there's like
basketball cords yeah it was like
swimming pools there's it's just so fun
man the [ __ ] Korean church that I
went to as a kid yeah we used to play
ball it was at this back area at the
church lot that had weeds crack but
there was no basketball net yeah rusted
his [ __ ] at that place they tore that
[ __ ] down and they built a [ __ ]
basketball court indoor basket and where
the [ __ ] was that when I was a kid dude
well they changed her business practices
right but I mean anything see that's
that's a huge part for me when it comes
to religion it's like
it's like I feel kind of sick in the way
that people get taken advantage of yeah
so a lot of people join religion because
you know they're lonely they're hurt
they're they need help and they might
receive some type of community warmth
and and and stuff that they mean through
religion but there are a lot of people
that take advantage of that power and of
that insurance because there's corrupt
human beings exactly well aren't perfect
you know and I you know to the credit of
you know Christianity that I've been a
part of yeah I've learned a lot from it
as a human being yeah and I think that
too that religions credit it did help
mold a lot of values in my life that I
still keep till this day like I
definitely don't think I would have been
Who I am today without it in terms of a
lot of the positivity and there's a lot
of great memories that you build like
community the sense of belonging the
sense of giving is what I received back
from Christianity was and what you're
supposed to do in this world the sense
of purpose yeah and I think a lot of
those things I